one of the cool things about travel
right you you broaden your perspective
and your understanding of what it means
to be a person and go to these different
environments and try self - yeah yeah
they're different and they're different
foods or different art and they're
different architecture and you go this
is also possible - yes people can live
like this
yes and you even begin to see why they
live like that you know like you
initially you go to Greece and you have
resin flavored wine you have it at Sina
and you're wondering why would these
crazy Greeks put pine resin in their
ruining a perfectly good white wine and
then after a while you start to say hey
actually it's pretty good
you know this is not a crazy thing after
all in the acquired Kaiser and resin and
they're wrong
yes you know the first time the first
time I had scotch whiskey I didn't know
what I thought about it and now I love
whiskey right it's an acquired taste so
the first time you drink something like
that you think you know yes they put
resin they put pine resin in their white
wine they chill it I should have brought
you so many and you sound an acquired
taste what's not oh so kool-aid it's
delicious from the beginning yeah yes
yes I'll have to convince anybody yes
that's right that's right some things
that's right some things are just good
right out of the box is good yes it is
just good yeah I mean I don't recommend
you drink it all the time it's full of
sugar it's terrible for you but damn
that stuff yes good it's like it's like
it's like fried foods you know yeah
just yummy a lot of them yeah french
fries yes I mean come on man salt and
ketchup yeah like that one
you don't like that no I'm uh I'm not
sure about what I should mention but
anyway I love pops fried chicken I do as
well I love it so bad it's awful
my wife is unlikely to listen to this
full podcast so or I'll skip over this
part so she doesn't hear this part but
and my sister will be listening probably
and so she will laugh when she gets to
this part because whenever I just pull
over and indulge myself and then I
terrible terrible tapas is good yeah I
know what if you really want to indulge
yeah and you like chicken Roscoe's yeah
but no you don't know no I don't
Roscoe's chicken and waffles oh I try to
go there
family we tried don't you make that with
my family hour and a half wait on the
same place Sunday
well of course on the same plate what
are you a communist yeah man it's is the
Watership to hell yeah and butter yeah I
mean the cheese on there yes perfectly
delicious from another planet so don't I
I make maple syrup I live in Vermont and
I make maple syrup I tap my own trees
and wow what a freak I have I have it
yeah giving people a hard time for
waffles and chicken the kernels a liar
that's not even the kernel no the
Colonel's nor McDonald very like
promotion or something this is nonsense
but they do yeah that chicken and want
that waffles and chicken tastes like cat
litter compared to Roscoe's also sweet
chick la he could try to get this out of
here so Roscoe's okay so we get the
Greens to the collard greens I like yeah
that's fine damn good that's fine but
that's a waste of maple syrup take it
from a man who makes it to push me a
check is good I'm sorry it's nas's place
I get it I love it I get I've been there
it's great Roscoe's okay was an hour and
a half wait on a Sunday okay how long
you in town for just the day maybe I'll
be back though I'll be back right after
the show maybe I'll go there put one on
Goward oh man it's good all right maybe
I'll try that it's so good and it's also
one of those places been there forever
we used to get it I found out about it
from 19 1994 when I was doing news radio
95 ish I guess you been in LA since you
left
Massachusetts no I went to New York for
a couple years then I moved out here I
moved out here in 94
okay it's been here a long time yeah and
when I was on Newsradio they got it for
like you could order lunch and someone
ordered Roscoe so she came addicted what
is this like waffles it was just like
yeah waffles and chicken there it looks
that's that'sthat's doesn't look as good
as it looks when you're there when
you're there and you smell it it's damn
good
you're doing a Rosco's commercial here
that's an incredible fan that's an
incredible combination of item it's so
good and afterwards you better have
nothing to do man food coma son anyway
um how do we get to that how you may
lose syrup stories no oh yeah I'm going
to yes different country different
countries and opening your mind so you
rez it yeah so you are counteracting my
resin flavored white wine with maple
syrup syrup yes well